allez on reste dans le loir et cher et
on ouvre à présent une page justice
rappelez-vous le drame a eu lieu il ya
quasiment trois ans le 1er avril 2018
togo du perche au nord de vendôme une
mère de famille être anglais ses deux
filles avant de mettre le feu à la
maison de son ex compagnon ou les
petites vivait jusqu'à la fin de la
semaine la cour d'assises du loiret cher
va tenter de comprendre ce qui a poussé
cette mère de famille a tué ses deux
enfants
compte rendu de la première journée
d'audience avec lucas chopin c'est une
mère éplorée et malades qui s'est
présenté à la barre de la cour d'assises
de blois ce matin nina est malgache
elle a 40 ans elle est bipolaire
lourdement dépressive pourtant bien que
significativement altéré d'après les
experts son discernement n'est pas
abolie lorsque le soir du 1er avril 2018
elle étrangle de ses mains maeva 9 ans
evans a quatre ans ses deux filles morte
elle met le feu au domicile de christian
son époux duquel elle est en train de
divorcer mais elle échoue à se donner la
mort
aujourd'hui elle reconnaît les faits et
explique n'avoir pas supporté que son
mari souhaite refaire sa vie à
madagascar avec ses filles très
perturbée elle a tenté à plusieurs
reprises de se suicider depuis son
incarcération depuis qu'elle est en
maison d'arrêt elle séjourne à chaque
fois à l'unité psychiatrique
elle pleure énormément et elle regrette
son geste puisqu'elle pensait pouvoir
partir avec ses filles nina est très
pieuse et c'est en partie ce qui
explique son geste d'après le psychiatre
qui l'a examiné
elle aurait souhaité emmener ses filles
avec elle dans un monde meilleur
la maire encourt la réclusion criminelle
à perpétuité
son avocate espère voir sa peine réduite
en raison de ses troubles mentaux